POLL OREPUBLICANS  LEADING THE
ASCEE  FLO GR RON DeSANTIS NIP O
PLAYEDUT
>> WE DON'T HE'S ONTRAI IOWA.
INeporter: SENDING A CLEAR BOUTA
>> HFOUGHT ASEO
DECIMATE IT.
HE VOTED TNG
MEDI. BDIIAL SECURITY.RUMP'SUS
RACE, WIT40% OF PUBLICAN AND E
BACK FORMER PRIDTRUMP.PPORTINGe.
NO OTHER G
NINEAL C
>>UMTERS ARE
TO STAY WITH TRUMP. PROHIMSELF.
SO WE KNOW WHAT HE'S CAPABLE OF
>> Reporter: WLEY OTERS
GRABS, THE P M
SUPPOR
IN.
>> N BUTRUMP.
>> TRUMP'S MY
THAT'S IT.
>> BACKING
UMP, SAY THEY'LL
DELY SUPPORT, COMPARED
TO FANTIS AND 29
FOR F THFIELD.>> I'M LEANINGORRO
AUSE O
ESTABLISHMENT -- TRUMS PARTE
>> RON A PAUWHY NG FOX.
>> Reporte DeSANTIS ISALIGNINGSN
THE E OFG LSON, WHILE TH  NATIO
DISPUTE BETWEEN UKRAINE ANS T T
POTENTIAL 2024EFULS, WHO TFORCE.
TOOIP OF THE REBLICAN
PARTY FOR APOLISCOUL
FREEDOM.
WD R T TH
eporteE L GROUP OFTERS WHO IS
TRAVELING ON THE PS THAT
HE REGRETTEDeSANTIS
BACK IN 2018 IN THE PRIMARY, OR"
NOW, IN THE ,
GIVEN THE FACT THAT HE H
NOW, A SP E, BUT
RTHER.RISTEN HOLMES, THANK YOU
LET'S TALK MORT 2024 ANDN'IVPOLL
JOINING ME NOW IS MY PANELSTEN
RESULTS OF CNN POLL.
U KNOW THE PS WELL,
OWS A LEADIAL REPUBLICAN CONTEN.
ROS THON
WHAT DTH
THE 2024 REPUBLICAIDENTIALHERE
DONALD TRUMP A
AN THERE'S CLEARLY ROOM FOR
FIRST OFLL
ESS.E AT THE BEGINNIF THIS
BU DOES SORTF ESMED TRUMP OR
U'THINKING ABOUT GETTING INTO TS
YOU'RE NIKKI HALEY AN YOU ARE
TOLCULOUS. AMONG THOSE
DEGREE, 48 TRUMP34
DEGREE, ITLI.VONTIS TO
WHAT I THINK IT SAYS FRO WE
KNOW FROM 2016, WHICH TRUMP HAS
REALLY REMADE THE REPUBL
PAY.
HIT THUECOLLAR REPUBLICANS, ANI
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE REPUANS T T
WERE OST
YOU SEE IN THAT , PENCE D
HALEY ARE ALSO DOING WELL WITH
COGRADUATEO OTHEINTO TEY
THAT MORE?
SAI THINK U ELGOOD THAT YO
COLLEGGRADUATES.
OESN'T SEE IU  TRUMP, YOU DON'T
MUCH MOROMGROWE GRAD.SS TCANDIDN
MORE ROOM SECOLLEGE
BUT HE CERTAINLY HASY
THOSE ON NON-COLLEGEYOU HEARD T
SOE DeSA, THERREAL CT YOU HAVE
RY EAT INTO E
N VO S
MEAN, I REPUBLIATLL REPLI ATHAE
I THINK RIGHT HEAJR INSTANCE,
SUPPORT RAR CHANGES BECAUS
DOT HEAR FROM PU
LEADORT UKRAINE 'RE FOR SOME RE
SCAR
THEARINGTUCKERW
N IS WHOWE DON'T
T MAKES  QUESTION HIS
N TAIWAN AND
SODVANTAGE RHT
IS, HE'SE ANYBODY
TH IROM
LIKE YEAH, I'MNGE
, IMFROM.T I DOT SANTIS TERSONA
HEAD TI EXPECT THAT DON
E A RON SAS T DONALD TRUMP WIL .
>>P SAID
REGRET ENDORSING
DeSANTIS RON DeSANTIS
WAS DEAD AS
' E HIMSELF TO
CERTALYSANTIS' RIBLICAN
FACT THAT THERE IS A
THE Y,ADAM WAS SAYING,OKLTO DOLN
ANON DeS A MO IIN
R
BU THIS MOMENTAT'S NOT
THPULARITY
PENG OR DONALD TRUMPS G ABOUT.AE
TH